Oh welcome to the first episode of ask
IJ let's get that first question out of
the way what's your favorite animal
panda bears
everybody's got a question on their mind
[Music]
J hey
the first and most important question is
who made that amazing theme song cuz I
know you guys are gonna ask it was my
good friend Jeff Smith who was an
amazing talented musician you may
remember that he also made me an amazing
ringtone back in the day hey Justine I
think it's kinda came with your iPhone
rings it's like you're making a saint
adjust speed you can find all things
Jeff Smith at the Jeff Smith calm you
can also find him on Twitter I Twitter
it up home slash Jeff Smith and for more
of Jeff Smith's amazing ringtones you
can find those a ringtone defeater mom
another question that I get quite often
is who is your favorite youtuber her
name is Julia and she probably has one
of the worst screen names on YouTube
it's Jay
a-a-a a-a-a-a J and then 70s so she said
what's the problem baby what's the
problem I don't know well maybe I think
about it every time I think about it
can't stop
over 74,000 subscribers and over tune
your profile views I don't think it
really matters how many as she has in
her name I think just one a for awesome
will do let's take a viewer response
video hey um you got a question for us
wondering what are you gonna marry that
uh that be just being good ah next
question
hey Justine a quick question
I've noticed you have a lot of really
good quality pictures and videos online
and it was wondering what kind of actual
cameras are you using to record that
video and to take those pictures also
what kind of software are you using I
know a lot of people would like to know
thanks hi Rachel that's actually a
pretty good question because that's
probably one of the most frequently
asked here's somebody that asked that on
Twitter there's a few on YouTube yeah
they ask it a lot anyways I just posted
this little behind-the-scenes video on
my other YouTube channel other iJustine
it's currently my bedroom so there's my
bed
there's my tripod and there's my my
computer and there's there's me during
the video and you can notice that I
don't always use the most professional
equipment I actually just use my
eyesight to shoot that well other than
the eyesight I use my flips which are so
compact and easy to just carry around
everywhere
[Music]
and edit I use iMovie and Final Cut Pro
that's it for the first episode might be
a little rough but we're working on it
and together we can make a pretty fun
awesome show and I can end set all of
your questions which will be great leave
a comment below with any questions that
you may have add a response video and I
may use it in a future video and also
most importantly follow me on Twitter
and you can ask me questions there just
type at iJustine with your question and
end it with a little pound sign and ask
IJ I use that pound sign also known as a
hashtag to be able to search for your
questions makes it a lot easier I'll see
you guys next time bye
[Music]